well speaking of holiday shopping let's
start today's show with
talking about a local store where
fashion meets entertainment and
the holidays this season it's the
perfect place for stocking stuffers and
gifts here's dewberry fashions
and candyland appears
each time you smile and that's pretty
good with a mask on
that's derrick david formerly of the
platters and currently
of dewberry fashion derek and his
illustrious wife that's what he called
her and i agree
opened this vegas staple 32 years ago
and really
you just can't get any more vegas
my wife had the same idea with her two
stores that she had in paris
where fashion and entertainment meet we
have become
one of the places to see when you come
to vegas
it's like it's become its own like
secret tourist attraction
because you can get pretty much
everything you need clothing
jewelry hats accessories makeup
toiletries
hats from arturo rios who has done hats
for like lady gaga
we have hats from philip tracy
we have watches we have ties we have
men's clothes
we have versace we have shoes
we have everything that you see here and
all
at the kinds of prices that everyone
needs here
especially with this kobe 19 thing going
on but it's more than a store
and a stage it's social everyone
who comes here they all fall into a
sociability thing
where it's like you can't wait to come
you couldn't wait for the shows we used
to have the shows
every saturday and the shows are free
while you shop we sing so
we that's what we do and as you can tell
we've done it and we we do it very well
this fine vegas establishment has lost
at least 50 percent of their business as
a result of covet 19
but derek and his wife ensure you are
shopping safely
at dewberry everyone who comes in okay
it's required you have to wear a mask
number two
i disinfect everyone's hands who come in
here
number three you can no longer put on
jewelry okay
uh if you want you can look at the
jewelry
okay if you wanted to you can pick it up
and bring it to the counter
but other than that there is no touching
of jewelry anymore
i know it's like telling a kid they
can't try candy at the candy store but
you're guaranteed to find something good
we want everybody to be
safe and we want everybody to come out
because
if you help the minority businesses if
you help all the businesses around town
then you're helping yourself as well
because that's what we all need
so come on down to dewberry fashions no
matter who you are we have
everyone from 19 to 95
that come in and from one family to
another
las vegas we love you